in the police report witnesses there in
Las Vegas Boulevard describe the attacks
now some of the victims apparently knew
that something wasn't right when Barrios
approached them Madison Kimbrough joins
us live with what these victims went
through
this area of Las Vegas Boulevard is
where the stabbing took place as
Witnesses say butios was seen running
out to large groups of people to quote
let out his anger
in the police report Witnesses and those
injured recall what they saw as
32-year-old Yani Barrios made his way
through the crowd Thursday just before
noon while the name of the injured have
not been released one witness states
that Barrios approached a group of
Showgirls near the main entrance of the
wind he had a set of knives on him and
asked the Showgirls to take a picture
with him and the knives and that's when
things escalated a witness states that
one of the women started to feel
uncomfortable and began to back away at
which point Barrios charged at her as
she started to run away that woman fell
to the ground Barrios could be seen
charging at 30 year old showgirl Maris
de Giovanni next she died of her
injuries then he ran off stabbing
47-year-old Brent Hallett in the back
Hallett died on scene another witness
recalls Barrios running towards him
holding quote a large kitchen knife
covered in blood that knife was later
located by police in the bushes
described as a gray 12-inch chef knife
with a black handle that witness also
saying that Barrios ran past him and
said sorry man before stabbing him in
the middle of the back the thus that
witness quote fell to the ground and
screamed for help as his wife applied
pressure to his wound and shortly after
police arrived
one of the victims also told the police
that he was on Santa Avenue talking on
the phone when a man with an object ran
towards him that victim then thought he
was punched in the chest but then saw
blood now I did connect with Maris
divani's family they say quote Maris
loved the beauty of life and lived it to
the fullest without limitations she was
a beautiful spirit and soul and we will
miss her for the rest of our lives
so Madison certainly you know stories of
survival and and just fear for these
victims can you tell us how the other
six victims are doing any update on
their conditions
so according to UMC one is still in
critical condition one is in fair
condition but two have been released
then we have those at Sunrise one in
fair condition and the other in good
condition Denise
glad they've been released thanks
Madison